persévérance le plus gros robots envoyés
sur mars par la nasa se posera demain
après un voyage de sept mois il s'agit
d'une prouesse d'ingénierie qui a
mobilisé des scientifiques et les
ingénieurs de partout dans le monde
farah ali b une québécoise de joliette
est ingénieur en 1re spéciale au jet
propulsion laboratory de la nasa
elle fait partie de l'équipe qui va
travailler sur cette mission de mais
c'est vraiment le grand jour et on la
remercie de prendre quelques minutes
pour nous parler je dis bien que demain
pour vous c'est un grand jour est ce un
aboutissement après ses sept mois sept
votes deuxième envoi de deux robots sur
mars mais là demain en quoi c'est un
grand jour pour vous mais en fait ça
fait sept mois que ce convoyage vers
mars
et là les domaines c'est les sept
dernières minutes en fait c'est les plus
importantes les plus difficiles du
voyage de mars et quand on rentrait dans
l'atmosphère les dernières minutes c'est
le temps que ça nous prend d'atterrir
sur la surface de mars et il faut que
tout se passe exactement comme planifié
pour pour qu'on ait un atterrissage
demain matin médiamétrie mort et vous
devez être faible et l'on perd le
sommeil sur ce défi leur madame à libé
oui suis énervé exciter un peu de tout
ça va être vraiment très difficile de
dormir ce soir c'est pas souvent qu'on
peut donc j'en profite toute l'équipe
est excité a donc ça fait un grand
moment de m alors quel est le fil et
celle des revenus de la plus grande peur
mais tous avaient tellement travaillé
fort qu est-ce que vraiment un risque ou
c'est certain que ça va bien aller
non il ya vraiment c'est vrai qu'à
vraiment un risque c'est ce qu'on a fait
de notre mieux on a on a toutes les
cités on s'est préparé on a appris
d'autres missions qu'on atterrisse sur
mars mais c'est quand même difficile
atterrir sur mars ont haussé à peine si
on comprend encore l'environnement
martien c'est possible aussi qu'ils
étaient en température de serre ferrand
où n'importe quel petit problème c'est
ça peut être catastrophique donc je
trouve ça qu'on est quand même un petit
peu anxieux
avec cette bouleverser le rapport au
temps les journées sont pas les mêmes
les années sont pas les mains
le temps d'envoyer lé message et tout ça
ça doit casser tour 10 ans non oui et
c'est donc là en ce moment par exemple
si j'envoie ma veste et d'envoyer un
message au beau ça prend environ 12
minutes de se rendre et 12 minutes pour
revenir une fois qu'on a atterri moi je
travaillais sur le temps de mars c'est
ce qu'on appelle on doit travailler la
nuit martienne mais une journée demeure
ces 24 heures et 40 minutes ce qui veut
dire que je vais avoir un décalage
horaire de 40 minutes par jour pendant
ces 90 premiers jours je veux dire que
j'ai envoyé une liste à maman d or qui
peut m'appeler pour chacun d'aller sur
mars
elle habite enfants je laisse mes sabots
permettrait parce qu'il ya des beaux
reportages vous avez été très généreuse
de votre temps pour des entrevues j'ai
mentionné joliette en ouverture comment
une élue en tout cas que c'est le film
apollo xiii qui vous avait donné la
piqûre une petite fille de joliette et
sud l'immigration de madagascar j'ai vu
que vous aviez été d'accepter de
d'intimidation comment on fait ce
parcours là que dans sa tête d'une
petite fille de 10 ans et qu'aujourd'hui
vous soyez à la nasa aux commandes d'un
robot qui va atterrir sur mars mais je
pense que pour moi l'espace et c'est à
partir de là je 10 11 ans ça a été une
passion et puis bon j'étais toujours en
train de bricoler ou mes parents m'ont
dit que j'étais toujours en train de
tout casser à la maison rien comprendre
comment tout l'art dans quinze jours
j'aime les physiques les battre l'espace
ça pourrait être un héros spatiale et je
me souviens à cette réalisation la salle
p j'ai trouvé ça au secondaire puis de
ce moment là je me suis dit mais je me
suis dit que il doit avoir des gens qui
travaillent à l'appui pourquoi ça serait
pas moi qui pourraient travailler la
dodge et je me suis dit je vais essayer
au moins au pire des cas je réussis pas
mais si ces gens à oreille
il faut que j'essaye puis c'est ce qui
en a eu des échecs tout moment c'était
quoi ton chemin mais ce n'est pas un
chemin direct il y en a eu bien des
détours mais moment où on me dit non des
moments où j'ai échoué mais je pense
qu'à chaque fois c'est un rêve que je
voulais tellement atteindre que j'écris
et je redemande genre envoie une demande
de stage job
et puis éventuellement je me suis
retrouvé ici comme quoi le sont
un bon nom pour vous persévérance c'est
la clé de votre mission à vous non un
rift avez raison c'est même pas réalisé
en voyez vous mais ça c'est le l'idée de
cette rencontre
quand même c'est un projet de longue
durée vous voulez ramener des si je dois
faire ce qu'on dit des échantillons sur
terre des artefacts sur terre mais ça va
prendre encore plusieurs années
ce serait votre plus grand rêve de
pouvoir analyser ou de participer au
retour sur terre de ces éléments là non
plus oui mais ça c'est déjà un honneur
de faire partir de l'équipe qui va aller
chercher des échantillons qui va
commencer à se poser ces questions-là
est ce qu'il ya de la vie sur mars ce
qui a eu la vie sur mars est ce qu'une
la vie ailleurs sur terre mais là c'est
pour aller rechercher persévérance à
prendre les échantillons on va les
laisser sur la surface est vaste si vous
pensez pour aller les chercher ces
échantillons là va falloir à tenir une
autre mission il va falloir une fusée
sur mars dans laquelle on va mettre les
échantillons qui va les ramener vers la
terre on s'imagine dungu l'ingénérie
commencé déjà compliquée envoyé une
physique de la terre maintenant
d'envoyer sa dans une planète à des
millions de kilomètres pour ramener ça
c'est c'est comme du côté des jeunes et
c'est vraiment ce que ça va être un
avancement technologie puis je veux
faire partie de l'équipe qui va faire
donc j'en avais au moins pour 9 10 ans
encore le de la nasa et sur ce projet là
c'est votre bébé
et qu'est ce que c'est d'être une femme
ingénieur à la nasa en terminant ça
s'améliore quand j'ai commencé mes
études on est à environ 20% de faire mon
ami on se retrouve à un peuple est plus
30% ce moment 30% femmes 30% minorités
visibles
ça pourrait mieux je veux dire c'est
aussi souvent les équipes que c'est des
hommes est une chose que j'ai appris
c'est de prendre ma place qui une classe
pour moi à la nasa et que je peux
réussir
puis j toulouse maintenant ma plateforme
pour encourager d'autres femmes
encourager d'autres minorités à
poursuivre leurs
aussi c'est pas parce qu'on voit à la
télé des gens qui nous ressemblent pas
que nous on n'a pas une place à la câble
dans l'instant sur michel camptort très
certainement sera libre en nous donnant
des entrevues en nous parlant des temps
aussi accessible vous êtes faire fondre
les modèles x et y avait une petite
fille de dix ans quelque part qui va
vous voir vous entendre votre robot
aussi je vais la lonase un jours merci
beaucoup on va observer doigts pour vous
demain on vous envoie tout notre notre
énergie solaire et puis on vous suit de
près demain
merci bonsoir et merci beaucoup au
revoir